RICH MINER: OK.
Welcome, everyone.
Very exciting speaker today.
For all of you, I bet a
bunch of you are in sales,
is that correct?
I know there's a formula
at the top of this book.
Don't be too intimidated.
Mark will go over it.
So don't worry about that.
And this is Google
after all, so I
think this is a very
appropriate talk about how
to use data to drive sales.
Mark Roberge from HubSpot is
here to talk about this book.
And I'm not sure
if you guys know,
I'm Rich Miner from
Google Ventures.
We actually invested in
HubSpot several years ago
and rode that through its
initial public offering.
And that's when
I first met Mark.
Today, HubSpot's trading
at about $1.6 billion.
Mark was employee number four.
Started the sales there after
graduating from MIT Sloan.
And that was his first sales
job, which he'll talk about.
And he grew it from,
basically, $0 in sales
to over $100 million and
to where it is today.
And so without further ado, I
will let Mark hop up on stage
and tell his story.
MARK ROBERGE: Thanks, Rich.
Thanks, guys, for having me out.
Thank you, Rich.
One of my favorite things
about coming to Google
is I love using Google
Maps to find Google.
It's like you guys need to have
a take me to your master button
just to make that
super straightforward.
But, awesome to be here.
It's been great getting to
know Rich over the years
and watching the
HubSpot journey.
As he mentioned, I met one
of our co-founders, Dharmesh,
sitting next to him
in class at MIT.
He had this business
idea about HubSpot.
He invested in a startup
that I was doing.
As part of that deal, he asked
that I help him out one day
a week.
And that was my
venture into HubSpot.
I decided to join full-time
and join as a fourth employee.
Scaled up sales and service
to about 425 employees
and got the company to about
$100 million in revenue.
In the last two years,
I've been working
on getting us into the sales
product arena, which I can
talk to about during the Q&A.
But it's that first
journey that I'm
going to tell you about today.
What people get a
kick out of the story
is, as Rich mentioned, I've
never been in sales before.
This was my first sales job.
Probably like many of you, I
studied engineering undergrad.
I started my career at Accenture
back in the late '90s, writing
Java and et cetera.
And I have a degree from MIT,
which tends to be quant-based.
So my professional
world has always
been viewed through this
lens of data, and technology,
and science.
And it was that lens
that I used to challenge
some of the norms of
traditional sales execution.
And that's what we're
going to talk about today.
So when I took the
role, really, my mission
was predictable
scalable revenue growth.
If some of you ever decide to
go and found your own company,
and do a Series A or a seed fund
to pitch to a guy like Rich,
write these four
words on the screen.
They all love it.
Scribble it down.
That's what we want too.
So that's a good place to start.
There were four tactics that I
used to achieve that mission.
The first one was,
how can I hire
the same successful
salesperson every single time?
The second was, how
could I train them
in a very predictable way?
The third was, how
could I provide them
with the same quality
and quantity of leads
every single month?
And the fourth was,
how could I hold
them accountable
to the same sales
process against those leads?
And I figured if I could
achieve those four tactics,
I'd have a high degree of
likelihood of succeeding
against my mission.
And these are the four sections
we'll talk about today.
So hiring.
And I typically
stop here and ask
the audience, what do you
look for in a salesperson?
Or if you were to hire a
salesperson as a founding
entrepreneur, what
would you look for?
And I do that because the
audience has no clue what
they're talking about.
In this case, I'm very envious
of the very scientific approach
that Google takes, so maybe
I'll pose that question
in hopes of maybe
learning something here.
But are there sales?
I know Rosenthal's a
hiring manager here.
Are there other hiring managers
in the audience for sales?
So just what do you guys
look for in sales hiring?
AUDIENCE: Process-oriented.
MARK ROBERGE: And how do you
look for that in the interview
process, briefly?
AUDIENCE: We have them describe
a situation or situations,
and we tease that out, how
they approach problem-solving.
MARK ROBERGE: You want
to give me one more?
That's a good one.
I love that.
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: General
business sense.
Give them a business challenge
like starting a company
and hear how they think.
Especially if it's
something they
haven't thought
about before, just
to hear the level of thinking.
MARK ROBERGE: Yep.
I love that.
So we had business sense,
for the video there.
And we had
process-oriented there.
I love those.
So let me tell you a little
bit about a story that I had.
So when I first went
out and hired folks,
I think it was the seventh
hire I made in 2008.
And I was able to
nab the number one
salesperson from an 800 person
sales team here in Boston.
It wasn't Google.
It was a public company.
And I was psyched.
I had somehow
convinced them that we
were going to be the
next big deal in town,
and they decided to come over.
And I was surprised
that that person did not
crush it at our company.
I thought they would.
I thought they would come
in and completely teach us
how to sell.
And as I stood back
and thought about it,
and reflected on
that situation, I
realized that they came from
such a different context
than where we were selling.
They came from this
enormous brand.
They picked up the phone.
People knew exactly what was
coming in terms of the pitch.
It was a very
transactional sale.
It was usually a
same-call decision.
And they would do as much
activity as [? probable. ?]
That led to success.
That couldn't have been more
different than the context
that we were selling at
HubSpot in the early days.
No one had a clue who we were.
We told them we are selling
inbound marketing software.
They had no idea what
inbound marketing was.
It was a very evangelistic
consultative sell.
And it made be understand
that when hiring managers
and when entrepreneurs
ask me, well,
what do you look for
in a salesperson?
It's almost like an
irrelevant question.
Because it so depends
on their unique context,
and how complex their sale
is, who they're selling to,
et cetera.
So that was my first takeaway is
the ideal sales hiring formula
is different for every company.
However, I do
think that there is
a consistent process on how
that formula can actually
be engineered.
And I think this is something
that you guys do exceptionally
well.
And it's something that I
just, using my engineering
background, kind
of instinctively
try to go at this in terms
of predicting success.
So the first year, I
wrote down the 10 criteria
that I thought would
correlate with success
in our environment.
I clearly defined what
each criteria was.
I clearly defined what a score
of a 1 to 3, or a 5 to 7,
or an 8 to 10 would look like.
And I was disciplined about
scoring every single hire
against that criteria.
And the nice thing about
sales, unlike engineering
and marketing and
other disciplines,
is it's probably the most
quantitative function where
you can quantify success.
And by following
this process, it
allowed me to reflect
on the first six hires,
the first twelve
hires that I made,
and start to pick up patterns
as to what's predicting success
and what's not, and
iterate on that approach.
And it wasn't, long
probably about 18 months in,
where, as a young startup, I
was able to do a regression
analysis against
predicting success,
and attainment rate,
and revenue success,
and that kind of stuff,
with the criteria
that I was actually observing
during the interview process.
So this is the results of
the first regression analysis
that I did.
And this evolved a little
bit from where we ended up.
What was really
interesting about this
was some of the criteria
that you typically associate
with a good salesperson,
maybe in like a car sales
environment, something we
think is a traditional sales
environment, like closing
ability, convincing, objection
handling, those are actually
negatively correlated
with success in our model.
And things that
you would associate
with a great
consultant or a coach,
like preparation, and
domain experience,
and intelligence, those
were most highly correlated.
So I thought this was a really
cool outcome that there's
been a lot of chat about how
the buyer behaviors change,
and sales needs to change,
and all that kind of stuff.
And this was some form
of statistical proof
that the buyers wanted a
different type of salesperson
that was less the person that
was jamming concepts down
your throat, and more someone
that they could trust, respect,
get advisement from, and
appreciate through the sales
process.
So there were five criteria
over time in our context
that correlated with success.
And I do believe that in a
lot of tech entrepreneurship
situations, these five criteria
actually correlate pretty well.
I'll poll you guys to
see how you do here.
So these three are
all in the top five.
One of them is number
one, obviously.
So how many think intelligence
is the number one correlating
criteria in our environment?
How about coach-ability?
How about curiosity?
OK.
Cool.
I got you.
Curiosity was number two.
Coach-ability was
actually number one.
And what was really interesting
about that was coach-ability
wasn't even in my first
set of the 10 criteria
that I laid out.
It didn't come
until a year later
when I looked and saw some
people who were absolutely
crushing it at their
last job, but they
weren't doing well here.
And they were the types of folks
that just locked themselves
in the room and weren't open to
the training and the coaching.
They were like, you know what?
I know how to sell.
I've been selling for 10 years.
Let me just go figure it out.
And they were the folks that
actually ended up failing.
So it's something that
we had to really get out
in the interview process.
So there's coach-ability,
curiosity, intelligence,
work ethic, and prior success.
And if there's curiosity
on how I interview on that,
we can talk about
that during the Q&A.
So moving onto training.
What I found with
training was, I first
interviewed 30 VPs of
sales when I took this job
in the first year.
Because I didn't know
what the heck I was doing,
and I'd never done this before.
And I learned some
stuff from that process.
But I also found
some things that I
didn't like about the process.
And training was
certainly one of them.
It seemed like
when I asked folks,
how do you train
your salespeople?
They said, hey, Bob,
welcome to the company.
You remember, Sue, our
number one salesperson
from the interview process?
Well, you're going to sit
next to her for two months,
or you're going to ride
with her for two months.
And that didn't feel scalable
nor predictable for me.
So I wanted to challenge
that and create
a much more predictable
exam-oriented,
certification-oriented
approach, which we did.
We introduced a
sales methodology,
and that was very important.
What I found was,
over the years,
as I looked at our top
performing salespeople,
each salesperson that
was a top performer
for a different reason.
Like I had this guy, Adam, who
was an absolute activity hound.
Every time we generate
our monthly reports,
he had 40% more activity
than everybody else.
He would just crush the phones.
If you went and sat
behind him at his desk,
he had like five
tabs of his CRM open.
He was on the phone.
He was writing emails.
He was taking notes.
He was a multi-tasker.
He was insane.
And he was mediocre
at everything else.
He wasn't the best
consultative seller.
He didn't build the best
trust with his prospects.
He didn't do the
best discovery calls.
But because he had 40% more
activity than everybody else,
huge numbers came
out the bottom.
And then I had Jen.
And Jen was an amazing
rapport builder.
Like you listened to her
demos, the first half hour
was about sports, and kids,
and church, and the weather.
And she was best friends
with every prospect
that she spoke to.
Now again, didn't give
the best product demo.
Didn't give the best
discovery calls.
But because her prospect loved
her so much, many, many of them
bought.
Now they were both
top performing reps.
Imagine if Jen trained
by watching Adam or Adam
trained by watching Jen.
They would have
picked up bad habits.
They would have had
different perception
of their unique superpowers
and whether they
could use their superpowers
in our environment.
And I see that happen
time and time again.
So that's another
reason why I really
wanted to strive toward
this standard process.
Now beyond that
in training, there
are two opportunities
that we took advantage of.
One was because the buyers have
a higher expectation from sales
and want to learn
from them, we thought
it was absolutely
critical that we
strive in training to
put our salespeople
into the seats, the professional
seats, of their buyers
as best we could.
So in our example, every
single HubSpot salesperson
spends a good deal of
their 30 day training
building their own
website and their own blog
on the HubSpot software.
They generate a
social media following
of 100 plus followers for this
mini-business that they start.
They rank in Google
for dozens of words.
They set up landing
pages and run A/B tests.
They generate an email following
and nurture those emails.
They set up an
analytics platform
so that they can actually
measure the conversion
rates between each one.
And by the time they're
done with that training,
they can actually school
90% of the marketers
that they're going to
speak with on the phone.
And so I think that's a
big opportunity that I'd
like to see more companies
do is go beyond just
the typical product
training and try
to get these folks engaged
in the day-to-day lives that
are better sellers.
The other opportunity
that we had was there's
an opportunity for
the salespeople
to build up their own
personal brand and trust
within the ecosystem.
So many corporations and
brands are doing a better job
on their content
marketing strategy
and their inbound marketing
strategy these days.
And trying to come
up more organically,
whether it's in search or
social media discussions.
That same opportunity
exists for the salespeople.
And I encourage our salespeople.
And even when I go out and
meet other salespeople,
and they'll talk to me.
They're like, Mark, I
cold call 50 hours a month
in order to generate demand
for myself and my company.
I say, that's the reality.
It's a sales job.
You need to cold call.
But here's what
I'd like you to do.
Next month, spend 40 hours
a month cold calling.
And use that 10 hours
a month that you saved
and actually participate
online where your prospects
are actually conversing.
So what blogs are your
prospects following?
Read those blogs,
comment on those blogs.
In fact, submit a guest
post for your blog
if you have a corporate blog.
What LinkedIn groups are
your prospects a part of?
Get involved in
those LinkedIn groups
and answer those questions.
On Twitter, who do
they follow on Twitter?
Follow those same people,
and retweet their stuff.
And you'd be surprised
that those people
will start following you.
And then do that for two months.
And then ask yourself,
were those 10 hours a month
spent better cold calling,
or were they spent better
participating in social media?
What kind of action did
that stir up for you?
And I think most
salespeople find
that that was a really
productive process,
and they may actually double
down on those efforts.
So there's certainly
an opportunity
out there for
salespeople themselves
to set themselves up
as thought leaders.
And that's something
that can be incorporated
into training as well.
Third section, same quality
and quantity of leads.
How many people in
the last six months
have received a cold call,
either at your office
or at your home, and you got
into this engaging conversation
with the telemarketer,
and you ended up buying
the product they were selling?
There's usually like one,
like a timeshare or something
like that.
I had one that called me.
He said, do you have a
crack in your windshield?
I said no.
And they just hung up.
That's what these people
are doing in these jobs.
I don't know why they do this.
How many people in
the last six months
have received a piece of direct
mail or an unsolicited email
to your inbox?
You opened it, you
were intrigued,
and you ended up
buying the product.
What was it?
AUDIENCE: Clothes.
MARK ROBERGE: Clothes?
OK, you're fired from Google.
You're not supposed to do this.
That's cool.
It's unique to find that
amongst the audience.
But that's cool.
What brand was it?
They get me too.
I always get the
catalogs and stuff.
AUDIENCE: I'd rather not say.
MARK ROBERGE: OK, that's cool.
I'm a big fan of
Pistol Lake these days,
like the startup
hoodie thing going on.
But yeah, you don't
have to tell me.
How many people in
the last six months
have gone to Google to do a
search or out into social media
to do some research
on a product,
and that research led
to you buying a product?
OK, so the folks in
this room has probably
had the biggest influence of
any company on this trend.
But this is the reality
of the buying journey
that we're dealing
with today is buyers
have complete empowerment.
And they don't have
to go to trade shows.
They don't have to deal with
these interruptive outbound
marketing, as we call it.
They can be in their bunny
slippers on a Saturday night,
doing research after
the kids are asleep,
making business decisions and
choosing the vendors they're
going to do business with.
And what's really interesting
and still an opportunity
for us, and obviously, a huge
amount that you guys continue
to take advantage of, is
when you go back and resurvey
most audiences and
ask them, where
are they spending their
sales and marketing budgets?
How much are they
spending on trade shows,
and interruptive
advertising, and cold calling
versus how much are they
putting into content
and the efforts that can attract
people to their businesses?
There's still a
huge disproportion
to the buyer behavior that we
just proved out in that survey
and proves out time
and time again.
And that's a big
opportunity, obviously,
that we've always tried to
push is this inbound marketing
message leading into content.
And the thing that most
businesses don't recognize
is the importance of
content development
and the journalist's
role in that.
I was actually just speaking
to a startup on the way
here, down in New York.
100 people, starting to build
out their marketing team.
And it amazes me, to this
day, that it knocks them
off their seat when I tell
them that our second hire
in our marketing team when
we were only 20 people
was a journalist from
the "New York Times."
And that's really how a lot
of these marketing teams
need to be thinking.
It's less about these folks
who have product marketing
backgrounds, and trade show
booth skills, or direct mail
skills, and that kind of stuff.
And it's more about
people can just
speak to a neurologist with
a very deep PhD and great
knowledge in a space that
they know nothing about,
and actually take from that
hour-long cup of coffee
a beautiful piece that
layman folks can understand.
That's what a great
journalist can do.
And that person
and that skill set
plays an enormous role
in marketing teams today.
It plays an enormous role
in the demand generation
formula for many businesses.
The great thing
about that is it's
not a great time to be
a journalist these days
in a traditional manner.
The newspapers and magazines
are not exactly doing well.
And these folks are far less
expensive than a programmer
and far easier to find.
So not even they know that they
hold the keys to the future
of sales and marketing.
So we hope to see more companies
take advantage of that.
And the process
that we like to see
is once you find
that journalist,
they don't have to
necessarily have
domain experience
in the business
that they're working in.
That's really the
job of the business.
The CEO, the C-suite,
the salespeople
usually have great
knowledge of the domain
because they're talking
to prospects all the time.
So when you find that
journalist, coupling them
with a few dozen or dozens
of thought leadership folks,
a committee, within the
organization is advantageous.
And they can sit down once
a week for an hour with one
thought leader, and
they can interview them
and produce a five-page ebook,
and produce three or four blog
posts, and produce a few dozen
social media messages that they
can actually schedule
over the course of a month
from that one interview.
And those social
media messages go out
over the course of a month.
They point back to the
relevant blog articles.
And most importantly, at
the end of each blog article
is a call to action
that says, did you
like this blog article on XYZ?
Perhaps you'd like the
five-page ebook that we wrote.
And that is yours for free.
We just need your name,
phone number, email address,
and company, and
you can have it.
And that simple process
that didn't put a big burden
on the executive
leadership team, the sales
team, the engineering team
for content development,
really specialized it in someone
who can do that very well,
creates a huge
following in Google.
Lots of great organic traffic
coming to the website.
A really high conversion
rate from visit
to lead on your website.
And a nice stream of quality
leads for the sales team.
So this has done very
well for organizations.
The other thing
that comes up a lot
is aligning marketing
and sales, especially
at that mid-market
company level.
It's something that
we went through
and a lot of our customers
go through as well.
And a lot of the companies
that we go and visit,
we find that marketing and
sales has traditionally
not gotten along.
I don't know if
you guys have gone
through that at some point.
You probably did.
What I find often
is that marketers
feel that their salespeople
are overpaid spoiled brats.
And the salespeople
feel that marketers
do arts and crafts all day.
And that's the reality
of that relationship.
And then they go back to
their respective corners
of the office, and
do their cold calls
and do their trade show
booths and branding exercises.
And there's dysfunction.
And that dysfunction
is the kiss of death
in today's modern organization
when so many buying journeys
start online and need
to be eloquently passed
off to the salesperson.
So this alignment is
really, really critical,
and something that we worked
hard on in quantifying.
And so that's the first step.
We created this sales and
marketing SLA, service level
agreement, where we quantified
the deliverables from marketing
to sales and sales to marketing.
So as an example, we
knew in the first year
or two of our business that
for a mid-market salesperson,
if we gave them 100
inbound leads a month,
that they would
connect with half,
create 30 sales
opportunities, do 15 demos,
and close 5 customers
for roughly $800 monthly
recurring revenue per customer.
And that math worked very well.
So if we had 10 mid-market
salespeople, each needing 100
leads a month, it was
very easy to define
that SLA of 1,000
mid-market qualified sales
leads for that team.
And that was the journey
that marketing had to follow.
Sounds really good.
And if I found a company that
did that, I would say, great.
You're in the top
5% of your peers
in terms of the sales and
marketing alignment journey.
However, even that
sophistication
created misalignment.
And what happened was we
counted a VP of marketing
who came to our
website and requested
a demo as a qualified lead.
That was beautiful.
We also counted
a VP of marketing
from a mid-market company
that download a white paper
as a qualified lead.
That's a great lead.
Now any guesses as to which
one closed at a higher rate?
The demo request or the
white paper download?
Demo request.
It was about three times higher.
And which one is easier
for marketing to generate?
To get a visitor
to request a demo
or to get them to
download a white paper?
Right?
So even though we were pretty
sophisticated in our approach,
it still created a misalignment.
And sure enough, as the
month or quarter unfolded
and the marketing team
fell behind in their SLA,
all the calls to
actions on the website
moved from demo requests
to white paper downloads.
And the sales team
was like, what
happened to those
beautiful demo requests?
So Mike Volpe, our CMO and I,
sat back and thought about it.
And we're studying
the lead flow.
And let's take the mid-market
example in the upper-right.
We studied tens of thousands of
leads that were at the problem
education stage.
They had downloaded
white papers.
And those converted
to customers at 2%.
And when they bought software
from us, they spent $200,000.
I made these numbers up.
But you get the point.
Versus if someone
went all the way down
to the solution research
stage and requested a demo,
well, they would close
at three times the rate.
They'd close at 6% and
again, would spend $200,000
when they bought software.
So we simply multiplied
the conversion rate
times the average
revenue per customer,
and that got us a lead value.
So now, white paper
downloads were worth $4,000,
and demo request were worth 12.
And now I was in a
position to tell marketing,
I no longer need 1,000
mid-market leads from you
a month.
I need $700,000 of lead value.
And whether you
get there through,
whatever the math is, 1,000 or
so of the white paper downloads
or 3,000 or so of the demo
requests, that's up to you.
And this was a very,
very effective concept
and a cool concept when
you think we put marketing
on a revenue quota
just like sales,
and that kind of
accountability month to month.
And suddenly, literally,
the next week,
all the calls to actions on the
website went to demo requests.
And it was great.
Sales loved them,
more qualified leads.
And marketing was getting
the appropriate credit
for the hard work
they were doing
in driving that quality lead.
Now sales does not get off
the hook with this process.
They're equally accountable.
And what I would do is I'd
ask questions like, OK, when
I get a qualified lead, I know
we should call it right away.
I know we should call.
But if I do get voicemail, do
I call it this afternoon again,
or tomorrow, or next week?
Or when should I try it again?
And how many times should
I try it before I give up?
And as a sales leader, should I
give each salesperson one lead
a month and have them
call it 1,000 times?
Or give them 1,000
leads a month and have
them call them once each?
So obviously, the right answer
is somewhere in between.
But where is that right answer?
So another study, to
give you some examples
of some of this stuff,
stuff that you guys
do quite well as well,
is here, the x-axis
is the number of attempts
we made against these leads.
Some were only attempted twice.
Some were attempted 12 times.
And the y-axis is the
profitability of those efforts.
Because clearly, when you call
something more frequently,
your likelihood to get
on the phone is higher,
but it costs you more
in terms of your pursuit
of that account.
So wherever we could
maximize these behaviors
in terms of profitability,
that was the right answer.
So the orange line was
the small business leads,
and that maxed out
at around 5 attempts.
The blue line was
the mid-market.
That maxed out
around 8 attempts.
And the black line
was 12 attempts.
The black was the
enterprise leads,
and that maxed out
at 12 attempts.
So now I could go to the
sales team and say, guys,
we have calculated the behavior
to making the most money here
at HubSpot.
And that's what
salespeople like to hear.
And guys, we programmed
this into the CRM.
You don't even have
to think about it.
You go, you call lead.
The CRM automatically
notes that call
and puts that lead away, and
brings it back the next time
it should call.
And each night,
we're going to have
a report that goes out to
make sure that nothing's
fallen through the cracks.
And salespeople like
that, too, if you
start with a very
data-driven culture.
They like the fact that
this is my lead flow.
And I want to make sure
I'm optimizing the revenue
from that lead flow.
And I'm glad that the
system checks it for me.
So each night, a report
went out to the whole sales
team, the whole marketing
team, me, our CEO.
And it showed if any
of these behaviors
were not being followed
by the sales team
so we could act immediately.
And it also showed where we
were on this marketing SLA
so the marketing
team was accountable.
So we were able to
manage that demand gen
handoff on a daily
basis to make sure
that we had the right
demand feeding to the team
and to make sure
that that demand was
being acted on appropriately
by the sales folks.
And we were intervening
immediately if it wasn't.
So that helped us
out quite a bit.
Last section, then I'll
move to the questions.
So managing
salespeople and holding
them accountable to
the same sales process.
I wish we could rename
the sales management
title to the sales coaches.
Because I think that's
the most important thing
that sales managers
can do is coach
and develop their salespeople.
And the best and
simplest example
I can give in what I see
as effective coaching
comes from my
pursuit of the game
of golf, which has not been a
very successful pursuit today.
But I've taken many lessons.
And one golf pro said,
Mark, take a swing.
And I did.
And he said, OK, turn your
grip over a little bit.
Lean back in your stance.
Put more weight on your
right foot not your left.
Think 1 o'clock not 2
o'clock on your back swing.
And turn your wrist over more
when you contact the ball.
And I was like, you
gotta be kidding me.
The next golf pro was like,
all right, Mark, take a swing.
And I did.
And he said, all right, turn
your grip over a little bit.
Now take a hundred swings.
I did that for 20 minutes.
And he said, how's that feel?
I said, yeah, I can feel it.
That feels good.
So now start leaning back
in your stance a little bit.
Take another hundred swings.
How's that feel?
So a really simple example.
But I have promoted 17
sales managers at HubSpot.
Every single one falls into
the trap of the first golf pro.
Where they get a
new salesperson,
and they see the
90 things that are
broken with them of
where they are today
and where they want them
to be, and they throw up
on them for an
hour with feedback.
And you can just see
the rep's head spinning,
and they don't know
where to start.
And the best sales
managers and coaches
can actually see the 90 things
but focus on the one or two
that are going to make
the biggest impact today.
And they decipher and
diagnose that through metrics.
And I call that
metric-driven sales coaching.
And let me show you an
example of how that works.
So here's a really
simple sales funnel.
In the very
upper-left, you've got
how many leads each rep worked.
How many they generated.
Then how many they worked.
How many demos they delivered.
And how much
revenue they closed.
The different colors are
different salespeople
in a given month.
And on the right-hand
side, you've
got the conversion
rates between each.
So just to throw out
some examples here.
Let's look at the
top person in purple.
So if you were
their sales manager,
be a brave soul
here and tell me,
what would your coaching
diagnosis be here?
What do you see
in their activity,
and where are they broken
in the sales process?
AUDIENCE: They're not
bringing in revenue.
MARK ROBERGE: Yeah, low revenue.
AUDIENCE: Demos.
Lower demos than when you
look at who's coming in
with the most revenue.
So potentially, if they focused
more of their time doing demos,
little less of their
time doing leads work,
and really finding the
ones that are working well
for them, transitioning
those to demos quicker.
Then they might
get more revenue.
MARK ROBERGE: Right.
So she said, maybe a little
less focus working leads,
little more demos.
And that could get
to higher revenue.
I think that's a good diagnosis.
And what's interesting, whenever
I go to a non metrics-driven
manager, whenever they have
an underperforming rep,
they usually say, it's
an activity problem.
They just need to
do more activity.
And in this case, that's
far from the truth.
This person in purple at the
top is doing the most activity.
They're sourcing the most leads.
They're doing the second
most calls on the team.
But they're really bad at
getting them to the demo stage.
And they're really bad at
converting them to revenue.
And so we've got two
problems we have to work on.
We have to work on getting
prospecting demands to the demo
stage.
And we have to work on
closing demos to customers.
And I personally like to
start as high in the funnel
as I see a problem.
I can work on the
demo, but I just
don't feel like we have enough
at bat, as you pointed out.
So I need to look at the
leads that are working
and their effectiveness
at getting to the demos.
And my first question always is,
can I learn more from the data
by double-clicking?
And in this case, I can
in this simple example.
So it's either that they
are working lots of leads
but not getting them on
the phone, in which case, I
will see a lower connect rate
in the upper right-hand corner.
Or it's that they're
getting them on the phone,
but they are terrible
at breaking the ice
and getting them to move
forward in the sales
process, in which
case, I would show
a deficiency in the
bottom right chart.
And this is an
important analysis
because my coaching's going
to be very, very different
depending on my finding.
If I find that their
connect rate's low,
I have to look at the frequency
of their voicemails and emails,
and the effectiveness
of that, et cetera.
If they're getting
them on the phone
but just can't move them to
the next stage of the process,
that's not the problem.
I have to listen to
their connect calls,
and see how they're building
trust, and breaking the ice,
and aligning their particular
goals with moving forward
in the sales process.
So this is an example of
metrics-driven sales coaching.
Very, very important
for us in our growth.
And the more companies can
lean into this, I think,
it's effective in
developing that sale staff.
So yeah, the book
is there if you guys
have grabbed your copies.
One note I want to make
there, it did hit number
one in Amazon for
the sales category,
which we're psyched about.
But all the proceeds
go to build.org.
Is anyone involved
in Build here?
I just actually did their
business plan contest
this Saturday.
And what Build does
is, obviously, there's
some tough neighborhoods
here in Boston.
Some kids were not born
into the opportunities
that we probably all were.
And what Build does is
exposes these kids in freshman
in high school to
entrepreneurship,
and mentors them on how to
start their own company,
and does it for the four
years of high school.
And the kids from these
neighborhoods, they
probably have a 50% graduation
rate, maybe a 30% matriculation
rate into college.
And the kids that go through
this program, I think,
have a 99% graduation
rate from high school,
and an 80% matriculation
rate in college.
So I'm a passionate
entrepreneur.
And to take entrepreneurship
and add value
to these types of
environments is really cool.
So an organization to check out.
They've got an event coming
up later this month called
Tug, which is a
competition amongst nerds,
like volleyball, and
Nerf gun shooting,
and that kind of stuff, if
you want to check that out.
You guys are probably
already involved.
All right, that's my show.
So questions.
AUDIENCE: Super
interesting and all,
the data-driven approaches.
One thing that a lot of us
in the room do as salespeople
here is large customer sales.
Have you done any
research, any science
behind in-person
meetings versus phone,
virtual meetings,
and any correlation
between upselling and success
in terms of how often to be
in front of the customer?
MARK ROBERGE: I haven't.
We didn't get as much into that.
I know you guys, obviously,
that's a bigger driver for you.
We did move into the
corporate/enterprise space
in the last couple of years.
The trend I'm seeing
there, obviously,
is a lot more satellite offices
as opposed to putting people
in the territory themselves.
But I haven't seen that.
Obviously, there's
a lot more openness
from the buyer around
buying virtually these days
than say, 10 years ago.
And I think a lot of companies
that are starting out
building sales teams
are, especially
when they hire a
seasoned head of sales,
they probably don't
take advantage of that
as much as they could.
But I'm sorry, I
can't give you--
I don't have any data-driven
approaches there.
Sorry.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
AUDIENCE: Hey, Mark.
Thanks for being here.
My name is Heather.
I'm a sales manager here.
What is it like to have
Google Ventures invest in you?
What was the process like?
MARK ROBERGE: Total
micromanagement.
Worst VC to work with.
No.
It's awesome.
Rich obviously has an amazing--
the great thing about Rich
and, I think, the
Google Ventures folks
is they come with
operational experience.
They've been
entrepreneurs before.
They've had huge successes.
And those are the
types of investors
I personally like to work with.
There are some who are just
more from the finance side.
And they're putting
money to work.
And they might look
at it in front of LPs
and that kind of stuff.
But I like it when they
have those backgrounds.
And Rich and Google Ventures
certainly falls into that.
The other great thing is just
you guys are such a horsepower.
And to be able to have
tapped into various resources
here through that
relationship has been great.
I'll be quite frank, it's
more challenging to do that.
I have a lot of friends at
Google and know Rich well.
And often times, they
know just as much
as you do who you should be
talking to at the company.
It's such a monstrosity.
So it's becoming
more challenging
over the years for
the company to be
able to help the companies
from that standpoint.
But certainly,
our ability to get
in front of the
right people, it's
easier when it comes from
a fellow Google employee
than it does cold for me.
AUDIENCE: And just
a quick follow-up,
what kinds of resources
were you able to tap into?
I'm just curious.
MARK ROBERGE: In the
beginning, really around how
to build a great
engineering team, just
some of the best
practices on recruiting
and that kind of stuff.
That was really
important for us.
We struggled with that
in the first few phases
of the business.
Another example
recently was we're
making a big bet in the
sales software arena
and trying to go
heavy into freemium.
We've started with
a Chrome extension
and just getting featured
in the Chrome store, which
was huge for us in the
first phase of our growth.
So there's a dozen
other examples,
but those are the
types of things
that have been really helpful.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
AUDIENCE: Hey, Mark.
To do a lot of the stuff
you mention in the book,
you have to have your
salespeople use CRM.
And I know a lot of salespeople
don't like using CRM.
So can you give
any strategies as
to how to-- and
realistic strategies--
as to how to get a sales team
to actually use it properly.
MARK ROBERGE: Yeah, so
that's been the last two
years of my job, is taking us
into the sales software space.
And this whole question
is the cornerstone
of our thesis on entry, which is
most sales software has really
been built for the sales leader
to do forecasts, and pipeline
reviews, and that kind of stuff.
And the salesperson
has been left out
of the use case analysis.
And as such, so
many sales leaders
are left in a
situation where they're
getting 30%, 50% adoption,
and the original utility
for the CRM purchase
is out the window.
One thing that we did right
from the beginning was we
had a salesperson
first mentality
around the implementation
of our CRM.
So there has to be a very
clear, what's in it for them.
Like I knew that
I wanted to track
the number of calls
that were made,
and when they were happening,
and that kind of stuff.
But I also knew if I
told them to log that,
that wasn't going to happen.
So by integrating
it, having the calls
being initiated from the
CRM, giving them the ability
to use Gmail to craft their
emails but automatically
logging those emails in the
CRM, to have the CRM go out
and find and append
to each account
data that can be found in social
media and online automatically.
These are all examples of
things that the CRM should
work for the salesperson,
not the salesperson
work for the CRM.
So if you're an
executive looking
to increase your
usage of CRM, you
have to figure out this really
strong what's in it for the rep
to drive that data collection.
Good.
AUDIENCE: Hey, Mark.
Danielle.
I work in the Tech
B2B vertical, so a lot
of what you're talking about
with marketing SLA and sales
SLA really hits home as
a lot of our clients,
like email marketing, are
very lead gen focused.
Assuming that most
of our clients
aren't having these
conversations between sales
leaders and marketing
leaders in terms
of finding that right balance,
any recommendations for us
as consultative
and mostly having
the relationships on
the marketing side
to go in and broker some
of those conversations?
And what are the points
that would really
hit home into getting them
to think more in that model?
Because I think it would
really resonate well
with some of our clients.
MARK ROBERGE: Yeah, a
couple things in there.
One is to try to attach the
effort to a higher level
business objective.
Oftentimes, going to the CEO
or COO that oversees them
can be really effective
because they're there
to manage that misalignment.
And if you can get
into their heads
as to what's on the
agenda for this quarter
strategically, what's on
the agenda for this year
strategically, and how you
can get sales and marketing
alignment to solve
that, then that
will be more likely
to be pushed through.
And the other thing is we
have the same problem where
we start with marketing,
we try to get to sales.
In a B2B environment,
generically speaking,
the sales leader
politically tends
to carry more weight than
the marketing leader.
So you have a little bit
of a disadvantage there.
And the sales leader's going
to be less open to ideas
that originate from marketing.
So what's important for us is
to restart that conversation
with the sales leader,
not necessarily build
on the foundation that
the marketer has given us,
but just do it
from-- the marketer
cares about lead gen, and
visitors, and awareness,
and conversion.
The salesperson
cares about forecast,
and hiring, and demand
gen for their team,
and the quality of
leads, et cetera.
So just re-having a conversation
with the VP of sales,
almost restarting
the sales process
to understand their desires.
And then saying,
well, so it sounds
like if I could double lead flow
and the quality in XYZ areas,
this would be a very compelling
situation for you next quarter,
correct?
Would you like my
help in driving that?
So reframing it around
their terminology
has worked well for us.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, that's
interesting because even a lot
of the marketing, day-to-day
people that we deal with,
even when you ask
them what their goals,
and what their incentives,
and where their bonused on,
it's number of leads,
not quality of leads.
And it's not driving through
to that final revenue.
MARK ROBERGE: Yeah,
and the mistake
that so many of our
salespeople make
is they feel like
they've built trust
and have this amazing champion
internally with the marketer,
and leave it to them to
go talk to the VP of sales
or go talk to the CEO.
And I don't mean to offend
people in marketing,
but they're in
marketing for a reason.
They're not used to selling.
And that's really what it
takes when you go to the CEO
or you go to the VP
of sales, and you're
trying to make a change.
It's a sales job.
And so our best
bet as a sales team
is to get that direct interface.
And if the marketer doesn't have
enough trust to give it to us,
then we are a sales coach now.
And we're like, how are you
going to approach the CEO?
And do you want me to
build a deck for you?
And can I coach you through it?
So these are the tactics
that tend to work.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hey, Mark.
Thanks for coming.
My question was more on context.
And so you look at these charts,
and they're beautifully simple.
And I'm sure there's an enormous
amount of work and insight
that goes around them.
But what was missing for me,
or at least the question I had,
was timeline, right?
You were the fourth employee
at this company, which--
a startup has a very
different set of pressures
than Google because
you're trying
to get to the next
round of funding
and demonstrate
your business model.
But then you have this
enormously clear set
of data which is related to CRM.
So when you were building
the infrastructure,
what was the timeline of it?
This had to have
been a while, right?
So you had to deal with years
of frustration, probably,
not being able to answer
the questions you wanted.
And maybe now you're there,
but just that journey.
MARK ROBERGE: Yeah,
great question.
And to be honest, a lot of
the context from the book
skews toward the early
years, surprisingly.
So you probably need to
start this stuff earlier
than you'd expect.
And for example, in the
hiring, literally, I
went through that exercise
before my first interview
with candidates.
And yes, you're not going to
have a regression analysis
on your correlated criteria
after your first three hires
and after your first
six months in business.
But the important
thing is you're
thinking in the right way.
You're going through
that discipline
and you're setting yourself
up for that analysis
18 months down the road.
And even having made four hires,
say, in the first quarter,
and watching them perform
for three or four months,
you have something to work with.
You can go back and look at
that interview score sheet,
and reflect qualitatively
and make some adjustments.
So that was useful.
On the demand gen
side with the SLA,
it doesn't take a whole lot
to generate a few hundred
leads a month.
It doesn't take a lot for
a salesperson to make,
or a sales team to make
1,000 calls in a month.
So you start
sitting on some data
relatively quickly even in the
early infancies of a company
development.
So good question on timeline.
But a lot of these
things, I think,
need to be worked
on from day one.
And I think, in
this day and age,
it's surprising how quickly
data-driven insights actually
surface.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
AUDIENCE: Hey, Mark.
Thanks.
This has been very,
very informative.
Question for you on
the approach that you
have with holding
marketing against revenue
targets from a demand
gen standpoint.
I think it's brilliant.
And most of my clients are,
they sell marketing SaaS,
and none of them do this.
So they're behind
the 8 ball there.
But where I struggle with it
is in the world of selling B2B
SaaS, a lot happens before
you pick up the phone and call
someone or are ready to talk to
someone, let alone see a demo.
So what happens when your
marketing-- so Mike's team--
sends a $400 white
paper download
lead over to a salesperson?
Is that even ready?
Or do you further bake
it before it gets there?
MARK ROBERGE: Yeah, in
part three or something,
there's a chapter on this, on
the right times to hand off.
And I don't think I have
that in the appendix here.
But you'd have to imagine
a matrix of the y-axis
being the different types of
companies, the demographics
that really are static.
They're not going to change.
It could be company size.
It could be the industry
that they're in.
And then the x-axis is the
engagement, their journey
down the buying journey.
And so let's say it's enterprise
mid-market and small business.
And let's say it's low
engagement and then really high
engagement.
With the enterprise, those
are high-value leads.
The minute they
touch our website,
without even giving
us a name, we
should have someone calling
them because we're probably cold
calling to that group anyway.
The mid-market, that might be
more like when they give us
an email and phone number,
we should start calling them.
The small business
community, we want
to drive them all the way
through inbound marketing
education, product
education, probably
get them all the way to
this group product demo.
And whoever raises
their hand after that
will get a phone call.
And that's very much
how we drive it.
So you're being very
aware of the opportunity
size and the engagement cycle,
and differing that question
based on those.
And then you could have many,
many analyses within there.
For example, in the
enterprise segment,
you can do another buyer
persona, engagement level
based on the role.
So if it's the VP of
marketing, well, heck, we've
got to get on them right away.
If it's an IT
manager or an intern,
maybe we want to nurture
them, but we probably
want to nurture them
with different content.
So that's the framework you
want to set up, establish
some theories.
And then depending
on that theory,
you can start analyzing
the conversion rates.
And if there's a really
low conversion rate,
if you're passing leads
to sales and they're
closing 0.1% of them, well,
you drew your line too early.
And you've got to take
advantage of automation
to push that line to the right.
Versus if they're
closing 50% of them,
you've probably
sold yourself short.
And you should push
that line to the left
because you're leaving
some money on the table.
So that's the framework
that we went at it.
Cool?
AUDIENCE: Great, thanks.
Got some reading to do.
AUDIENCE: Hi, Mark.
Jillian Todd.
I'm one of our sales
account executives here.
So I just went on
my mobile phone
to learn a little bit
more about HubSpot.
And I noticed that you
guys are running SEO.
And actually, one of your
competitor's ad ahead of you
guys is pretty interesting.
It says, "wait,
check us out first."
I thought that was
an interesting.
MARK ROBERGE: Who is it?
AUDIENCE: Multi-Touch Leads.
MARK ROBERGE: Hm, OK.
Interesting.
AUDIENCE: So two
questions for you.
So two questions for you.
So first of all, it sounds
like you guys are obviously
a very lead-driven
company, which
is very much the
same business model
as a number of our clients.
So I would love to
better understand
how you think about Google and
how we're driving leads for you
and how you assess value.
Then the second
question is something
that we're challenged
with a lot of our clients
is because they are
so performance-driven
and typically think of
Google as being just
a low-funnel acquisition tool.
We're trying to help them
think about our inventory a bit
differently, and to think
about Search as a branding,
and an upper-funnel and
mid-funnel play as well.
So I would love to hear from
you if you guys have thought
about us in that same fashion.
And if you haven't, what
would resonate with you?
MARK ROBERGE: So
the second question
is do we get away from the
pure click, lead, sale,
and think more about
brand awareness?
AUDIENCE: Particularly
when using Search.
So we're thinking about
SEM, upper, mid-funnel.
MARK ROBERGE: Paid search.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, exactly.
MARK ROBERGE: Yeah,
so the first part
is we've run a lot of
experimentation, paid with you
guys, with Facebook, et cetera,
without a ton of success
relative to our other campaigns.
And part of me feels it's just
kind of like-- it would almost
contradict with our mission.
So I think there's a little bit
of a prejudice of the marketers
that join us.
And we're almost rooting
against the campaign in a way.
And I think part of it's
actually like the team is just
so good at content,
and with the buyers
that we're trying to
reach being marketers,
it's such an effective
channel for us.
So we've fairly invested
a decent sum of money
and actually hired SEM experts
to come in and do this stuff.
And it's just not an
enormous driver for us
because of that unique context.
Now I will tell you
that's a little bit
different on the sales software
with a different persona.
And we lean into
that a bit more,
both in the SEM as well
as the social media ads.
For us there in
the freemium model,
we find that the
more sophisticated
the ad platform is, obviously,
in terms of getting us down
to the specific
filters we need, that
makes the world of difference
of the volume that we're doing.
For example, knowing what web
browser they're coming from.
When these ad
platforms can filter
on that, which some can
and some can't, that
will drive a huge ROI for us.
In terms of the
branding piece, I
could probably answer it for
us and then for our customers.
Because for us, we're
just such on one end
of the spectrum of just drinking
the Kool-Aid on inbound.
Not just even questioning SEM
driving our brand, but even
just PR, like how even bought
in we are to that as opposed
to just going out there and
building our own TV station,
building our own radio
platform, building
our own major conference and
trade magazine, et cetera.
That's just our notion.
For our clients, it's tough.
I just think-- and
again, you're dealing
with me being a quant guy
over from a quant company,
I don't like things that
I can't clearly measure.
And I don't know enough
about the branding stuff.
There's probably
ways to measure reach
and all that kind of
stuff and awareness.
But I'm sorry.
I don't have a more
agreeable answer with you.
But that's my honest truth.
I'm just not
psyched about things
that I can't clearly measure
to lead flow and revenue.
AUDIENCE: No, that
sounds familiar.
Thank you.
MARK ROBERGE: Maybe
one more question?
Are we?
AUDIENCE: It'll be quick.
MARK ROBERGE: Quick question,
sorry, and then we'll be done.
AUDIENCE: So when you're talking
about-- my name is Daniella.
I'm an account manager
on the health care team.
When you were talking
about key attributes that
went toward success,
you mentioned curiosity.
So I'm curious, how do
you measure curiosity?
MARK ROBERGE: Yeah, the whole
interview process is outlined,
I think, in Chapter 3.
But it starts with the opening.
When I walk in, greet
you in the lobby,
and if you're very awkward and
I have to ask questions of you.
Or if you've done
your research and have
a natural conversation.
I like to start there.
Then I do a roleplay at some
point during the interview.
And I just see, do
you start by show up
and throw up, as we
call it in the industry
and give me a five-minute
elevator pitch on HubSpot?
Or do you actually dive into
why I downloaded the white paper
and ask good follow
on questions?
That's really how I
get my incentives.
And that's my
encouragement, often,
to people who are getting into
sales as a sort of fun exercise
on the side when you're
out on a Friday night
at a wedding reception
or a networking event.
Meet people and see how long
you can go asking them questions
without them feeling
interrogated or annoyed.
And it's something that
I just do naturally.
I enjoy it because
hey, I know about me.
I don't know about you.
And I'll literally have
20-minute conversations
with people who, whenever they
ask me a question, I deflect it
and immediate go back
to questioning them.
And they know nothing
about me except my name.
And they go off and
talk to their wife,
and be like, that guy Mark,
he's a really great guy.
And all I did was ask
them a bunch of questions,
but those questions made
them think differently
about the stuff
they were thinking.
Because they were
asked so well, and they
were truly genuine and curious.
Because I'm genuinely curious
about what you're doing.
So that's how I
measure curiosity.
Thanks for the time, guys.
Appreciate being here.